cuéntenos sobre la región del donbass y
su histórica importancia para rusia que
también el presidente ruso vladimir
putin quiso contar al mundo en su
discurso de hace un par de días
bueno la región de tumbas es una región
que tiene una historia compleja es una
región que fue poblada por los cosacos
inicialmente de la sitio de separos y
básicamente estaba ocupada por los
ucranianos durante mucho tiempo en el
siglo 19 comienza el proceso de la
industrialización de la región
cuando precisamente está cambiándose la
demografía de la región vienen muchos
rusos de otras regiones del imperio ruso
están llegando otros
grupos étnicos es precisamente porque
trabajo pero yo diría que durante una
buena parte del siglo 20 la población
sigue siendo predominantemente ucraniana
que tenía menos importancia porque era
un solo país que era la unión de las
repúblicas soviéticas socialistas que
ahora vladimir putin dice que fue
construido en los principios equivocados
y aparentemente lo que dice que quiere
regresar al inicio de los tiempos del
imperio ruso y realmente hacer la
historia lo que pretende hacer cuando
comenzó el conflicto en 2014 estos
territorios de donbass elegans que los
son centros industriales muy importantes
en ucrania
ellos sirven como bases de apoyo al ex
presidente y a yanukóvich porque muchas
de las personas que votaron por
yanukóvich provienen de este regiones y
con el apoyo de precisamente de él rusia
de prácticamente actuando directamente
bajo las directrices y muy pocos
escondidos de hecho directrices desde
moscú ellos logran el control sobre
ciertas partes de esta región de dónde
vas
y hay combates hay una guerra civil
durante estos ocho años y obviamente las
regiones que están bajo control de los
separatistas fueron financiados
totalmente por rusia ellos nunca
revelaron por ejemplo su presupuesto y
la razón por qué no lo hicieron porque
estuvieron recibiendo todo el recursos
desde moscú
a un periódico alemán bild que hizo una
investigación demostró que valor de mil
millones de euros es lo que hemos estado
realmente dando a estos regiones pero lo
importante que ellos no estuvieron
controlando todo el territorio de lo que
realmente es bombas y lugares que estos
poblados dentro del territorio de
ucrania y en la mayor parte de la
población ucraniana con el comienzo de
la guerra con el comienzo de los
combates como unas ciudades pasan de un
humano a otro
movió realmente abandonó estos
territorios controlados por los
separatistas prorrusas y están viviendo
ya en el riesgo de estos territorios
entonces cuando se dicen que estos
repúblicas que rusia reconoció son
progresos y porque la mayoría de la
población que se quedó allá realmente
son los rusos étnicamente yo creo que la
mayor parte de ellos si tienen
pasaportes de ucrania rusia estaba
llevando a cabo una campaña para
distribuir los pasaportes rusos y ahora
puede decir que son ciudadanos rusos y
yo creo que como 700 un millón de
habitantes estuvieron entregando estos
pasaportes en los últimos días en
últimas semanas pero el número real de
las personas realmente que se quedaron
en estos directores en el momento cuando
ya comenzó la guerra ahora es
desconocido porque no hay forma de
conocer precisamente las estadísticas
las cosas verdaderas
hay muchas de esa información que
proviene de estas partes no hay forma
independiente de comprobarlo lo que si
por ejemplo sabemos que para las
votaciones que ellos organizaron los
separatistas en donbass fueron
registrados apenas un millón doscientos
mil personas la última vez que
claramente es el número mucho menor que
cuatro millones de habitantes que
estuvieron en este territorio de cuando
antes de la guerra antes de 2014
precisamente eran la mayor parte de arán
los ucranianos